which one's your favorite
[Music]
mine's tracer
she's like she's not the cavalry's here
you're one of those heroes aren't you
before me i see the future
human
machine
you know there's more out there
don't you
even the best journeys end
but a new one
is right around the
[Music]
i corner your queen
let's take him to the wasteland
one punch is all i need
[Music]
nice work team
keep it moving
i cannot wait to push
[Music]
get in there
[Music]
it takes a team to tango
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone i am zoie schwindt and
earlier this week the community was
treated to some massive news regarding
overwatch 2. of course the biggest
announcement by far was the news that
overwatch 2 will arrive on october the
4th as an always-on always-evolving life
service game that will be free to play
for everyone now if you're like me
you're eager to learn more and that is
why i'm here today at the blizzard
campus to better understand the
decisions behind the announcements find
out what they mean for the players and
with some luck uncover a few new game
details for you at home and be sure to
stay tuned for the world premiere of the
new cinematic the wastelander which was
teased just a few days ago so with that
let's get into it
[Music]
joining me are overwatch game director
aaron keller and production director
paul hale first how are you two doing
i'm doing great excited
yes me too so excited to be talking
about this and i'm so excited to have
you both here now uh there was a ton of
news which dropped over the weekend and
the community has been
buzzing and i'm excited to be able to
sit down with you too now to unpack all
of this for everyone watching at home
now the biggest announcement had to be
the news that overwatch 2 is releasing
on october 4th as a free to play life
service that's incredible and that must
be very very exciting for you and your
team
yeah overwatch too it's been a labor of
love for our our team we're all
dedicated to creating a game that our
community will enjoy for years to come
we also want players to feel like there
was always something new for them to
play or experience in the game these
goals really led us down the path of
developing overwatch 2
as an always-on living game one that
continues to evolve and expand through
seasonal content drops and keeps the
game as fresh and fun to play
long after it turns on we're lucky to
have such a passionate and creative set
of players and
we know that they've been craving more
ways to play the game they love so much
in recent years we haven't done a good
enough job at delivering that for our
fans and we feel their frustration we
took a hard look at our strategy for
overwatch 2 to make sure that we could
deliver new heroes new maps
modes and more to the community on a
frequent and consistent basis
as an overwatch fan of course that's
music to my ears we know that's the
community's top priority and we feel
like we have the right approach to be
able to deliver that for them
well into the future how are you and the
team planning to deliver on that promise
uh well the very first step is getting
the game into everyone's hands and
that's going to happen on october 4th
when we transition over watch one and
invite every pc and console player to
drop in and experience overwatch 2's
reimagined pvp experience and that's
just the beginning our plan is to
deliver a steady drum beat of new
content every nine weeks through free
seasonal updates ensuring that there's
always something new to play chase
unlock in overwatch too well that all
sounds amazing it's so much of it too
and now i'm sure everyone at home wants
to hear more details of course uh i'd be
happy to share a look at the road ahead
our journey is going to begin on october
4th when overwatch 2 releases free to
play this includes three new heroes six
new maps a brand new mode and more the
new heroes include sojourn
junker queen and a brand new support
hero that we'll reveal in the months
ahead
our new maps will take players across
the globe to iconic locations
our new pvp mode called push will
challenge teams in new and exciting ways
players will also be able to unlock new
cosmetic items through the in-game store
and battle pass
as well as complete weekly challenges
and experience the start of competitive
play 2.0 and of course everyone will
also be able to access revamped heroes
pvp maps and fan favorite game modes
from the first overwatch game
our next season will arrive in early
december where we will introduce a new
tank hero along with a new map
we'll have more themed cosmetic items
for players to earn and unlock in an
all-new battle pass and also in the
in-game store and in 2023 we'll continue
to release a new season every nine weeks
with either a new hero new map or new
mode players will get the chance to earn
more themed content complete weekly
challenges
access new battle passes and more there
will always be something new to play
in 2023 we'll also begin releasing our
new pve experiences which we're really
excited about we're really looking
forward to being able to share more with
the community as we get closer to
releasing them i know we've seen more
and more games shift towards that
free-to-play model in recent years and
it really does seem like players have
taken the liking to it especially
shooter fans um did that have an impact
on deciding to make overwatch 2 uh go
free to play honestly
not really for us free-to-play games
offer a lot of advantages from the very
start overwatch was designed to be a
social experience we have heroes of
different roles and they all rely on
each other in in order to accomplish
their objectives in the game so it
requires a lot of teamwork we also see
that outside of our game within our
community with fan art cosplay and the
overwatch league we know our fans are
having the most fun when they're playing
with their friends or meeting new ones
and the move to free-to-play makes it
easy for everyone to just drop in play
the game join the community whether they
own overwatch one or not and with
overwatch two crossplay enabled people
can play together no matter what
platform they prefer to play on it's
always been a game that stood for
inclusivity and community when they see
the roster of heroes
we want them to feel like there's
someone there that they can feel
connected to because the overwatch
universe is and always will be a place
for everyone and we feel like we have an
incredible opportunity with overwatch 2
to really embrace it i can't wait for
october when this incredible journey
will begin for all of us now that we
have a better understanding of what's to
come i'd love to dive a little deeper uh
starting with oh two's new approach to
pvp can you maybe elaborate and explain
a little more sure
pvp has always been at the heart of the
overwatch experience and we've made some
tweaks to it over the years but
overwatch 2 really gave us the
opportunity to put the mode under a
microscope and we really wanted players
to feel that they had more impact in a
match and we've made significant
fundamental changes that we just
couldn't do in the current live game
this was a foundational shift that
changed everything heroes maps and more
so
we had to reevaluate every aspect of pvp
to ensure we got it right we've been
encouraged by player feedback from the
first beta and we will continue to make
updates and improvements in the game
well earlier today i had a chance to sit
down with a few additional members of
the oah team and hear more about all the
work they're doing to redefine pvp and
overwatch too so let's take a look
[Music]
one of the things that
gets us up in the morning happy to work
on overwatch it's first and foremost a
really special game the way we portray a
bright future everyone on the team is
really proud of it
we're bringing an all-new pvp experience
we're transforming from a 6v6 to a 5e5
changed a lot of how we design heroes
and actually how we balance them as well
we had to go back and look at all the
heroes and all the tanks especially and
make sure that everyone fits and works
really well on this new paradigm this
newfound importance on each individual
player to feel like they can really make
an impact on the game we're trying to
obviously maintain the original
character's identity and overall
silhouette colors statements but also
kind of bring something a little bit new
we can make balance adjustments really
quick as fast as our design team sees
that there's an issue jeff goodman and
the rest of the hero design team have
been loving all the feedback coming in
they have tons of awesome ideas about
how to change or adjust balance so
heroes like erisa got a major rework
we're looking at how many barriers are
in place you think about overwatch you
think of these really protective shields
we were looking at it from the
perspective of you know what if she
didn't have that what would that even
look like we're just always looking for
great opportunities to change for the
better
i'm really excited about how we've
refreshed all the maps i think we've
done a lot of great changes especially
for pvp a lot of our old stuff just
looks gorgeous now we've done a lot with
the art and with lighting and shadows
and just made stuff pop a little bit
more we also added some options with
like daytime night time i think all of
the overwatch team apps are custom
recorded in the actual place we've hired
a field recordist to actually go capture
ambience of the real world location we
realize it's a subtle detail but those
are the things that really make these
maps come to life we have done a pass
playing all the old maps in 5v5 and
adjusting things for that kind of setup
whether it's moving cover around just a
little bit or tweaking a door in the
beta we're listening to feedback so
we're going to improve each map based on
what the players have been seeing we've
been working on these for a little while
now and we're really excited about it we
were really happy with the positive
feedback once people were able to play
it and i think it was an important
milestone for us to get it in players
hands
[Music]
competitive play is a different thing to
a lot of different people and we really
didn't think we were providing enough
tools and measures to actually help
players out if they did want to improve
we're reworking our scoreboard to
provide more information to players as
they're like playing through the match
but then once they finish the match
we're actually going to provide an
after-action report so you can look at
the report while you're in queue you can
actually go into
your history section and look we want to
work towards providing you with
information that will help you
improve your game
we've been getting feedback from a lot
of different areas from our you know
community team like streamers
influencers we've also been getting a
lot of feedback from overwatch league
players we do want to actually provide a
bit of like feeling of progression so
one of the other changes we're making
alongside that is not making your skill
rating quite so granular right now it's
a very hard number instead of numeric
skill rating we're adding these skill
tiers within the larger ones if you see
someone at a really high skill tier you
know that that person is not just that
good of an overwatch player but they've
earned it
one of the cool things about overwatch 2
is it has this new push game mode and
maps along with it push is a pvp game
mode on several different new maps we've
been playing it in the beta and we've
actually been using it in overwatch
league as well and once we started play
testing it it was kind of an instant hit
there's
a level it has one path that goes all
the way through it from one base to the
other and the middle is ts1
and he's this lovable robot with a pair
of barricades next to him and the
players essentially fighting for control
and if they take control by taking out
the other enemy team ts1 will move a
barricade towards the enemy base to win
you either get that barricade all the
way to the enemy base or after a certain
amount of time did you move your
barricade farther than the enemy team
did it's a very fair game mode i think
the maps are great it provides for a lot
of different like locations where a lot
of great fights can happen
we've developed a lot of engine upgrades
in the game so this allows us to do
faster iteration this was a huge effort
by our engine team to allow the art team
to build faster more detailed
environments in a shorter amount of time
you will get to experience the game
world we wanted to feel much more
immersive
overwatch 2 is a dream for audio
features it's everything we've ever
really wanted to do we we really go into
every little bit of detail trying to
find
a way that every sound will cut through
when we started on overwatch one we were
really really focused on the headphone
mix we we thought for you know a pc
first kind of game
we realized that people listened to
overwatch in all types of different
places so now we support home theater
dolby atmos in the game
now consoles offer all kinds of new
things too like 3d audio that we're
supporting there's new voice lines new
conversations between all of the
favorite heroes and we have so many
there'll be more that'll just come to
the game over time we've written 25 000
voice lines for overwatch
dude so tons of new features and the
reality is that overwatch scales even
beyond that all the way up to giant
sports arenas for our overwatch finals
everything you like about overwatch
you gotta get that in overwatch too but
even more you know we're really
listening to feedback a lot of it we
felt like man we really think this is
gonna be super fun we just need people
to be able to play it
october 4th is really just the beginning
i mean just amazing work by the entire
team and i personally can't wait to
finally get my hands on the full pvp
experience when overwatch 2 goes live
this october and october is just the
start as paul mentioned earlier
overwatch 2 will continue to evolve and
grow over time but what does that mean
for us the players well i went behind
the scenes to talk with the team working
on new seasonal content and find out
more so let's take a closer look at what
players can expect when overwatch 2
expands post launch
[Music]
we're really excited because people will
just be able to just fully immerse
yourself in the maps and the story lines
and the heroes
with the new seasonal model we'll be
able to drop a ton of content in very
frequently as we're updating the game
through these big seasonal drops
we're looking at releasing heroes every
other season and then a map in between
those and on top of that we're looking
at dropping a ton of content involving
skins and other great goodies for
players to get their hands on for each
seasonal drop
we have so much that we want to do in
overwatch to develop this game because
we think it's the next step for us we
think there's so much more we could
bring i'm really happy moving to our new
seasonal base schedule making this
really huge commitment to regular
updates it's exciting at the same time
because i know what this team can do we
really want players to be able to
anticipate when things are going to
enter the game with all the new content
and events coming in it's even more
important to just make sure that
everybody knows what's coming and along
with the free to play change we're doing
away with loot boxes entirely we have a
new battle pass model coming in and we
have store as well so players will have
a lot more control about how they
interact with the game and how they
acquire new content
we've been working on so many things
over the past couple years i'm most
excited for folks to see some of the new
heroes that we've been kind of cooking
up it's a bunch of different reasons why
we choose to make a hero we're trying to
follow the narrative pick the hero that
makes sense or do we need to create a
hero that answers this mana counters a
certain strategy that's too strong in
the game we've got two more supports and
another tank in just the first couple of
seasons and we're still working on new
characters for a year year and a half
down the line as well there's characters
that folks have already seen glimpses of
in the story and there's also characters
that you've never seen before never
heard about
we were looking at making sure that new
heroes fit within this new very
fast-paced paradigm and less shields and
crowd control you can see a lot of that
reflected in team play moments but with
a much faster pace vibe
we want to push the sci-fi the
futuristic feeling of maps there's a
touch of sci-fi everywhere you look so
this is something that was a bit more
subtle in overwatch one we really want
players to feel that the world takes
place in not so distant future coming up
next is rio rio new pvp map pretty sure
everybody's gonna love that one as well
it's a great map it's close to the team
many people on the team are from brazil
so it was kind of fun to inject the
culture the colors the vibe into this
map
there's a map that takes place in
portugal this map is pretty close to the
team because our lead environment artist
he's from portugal
people from the location should really
get a sense that we've done a ton of
research
and we were very inspired and i think we
captured it pretty beautifully in the
game it is a push map one of the newest
game modes and we tried some pretty
interesting layouts for this one so we
hope the players like it we definitely
want the game to feel like a globe
trotting adventure
there's new types of content from what
you're used to in overwatch one we have
charms we have banners
the current make the skin that's in the
works that i worked on actually is genji
he's got this kind of cyberpunk japanese
demonic theme mythic skins are meant to
be this
next tier of skins above legendary we
want players to be able to go in there
and pick and choose certain pieces meant
to be this extra awesome legendary skin
that you can customize we're
concurrently developing quite a few
mythic skins they're going to be
released over the seasons all this
amazing stuff all of the amazing skins
for weapon charms really what we're
looking for there is just for the
players to be able to express themselves
and dress their character up one of our
core tenets on overwatch visually is to
focus a lot on the first person view we
want you to be able to see it and enjoy
it while you're playing the game one
thing that was really important to us
was to make sure that players if they
earn anything in the game anywhere that
they're able to use it everywhere so if
you earn something on console or a pc or
an overwatch one you can always use it
in anywhere in overwatch too as well and
with each new season there'll be a ton
of new content and a new battle pass as
well
these seasonal updates will allow us to
be constantly infusing the game with new
content new heroes new maps so the game
is going to feel fresh just all the time
there's always going to be something for
you to do or to work towards there's
never going to be a point where you're
like gosh i don't have anything to do
being able to provide players with new
heroes every so often new maps it is
going to be a growing and evolving game
there's so much for us to explore as we
move forward get ready it's going to be
really exciting really fun
with both pvp and pve there's going to
be really great content for you to
immerse yourself in and continue to play
over and over again with your friends
we can't wait for october 4th we're just
excited to be back
i mean it's so great to see how much a
thought and care your team is pouring
into
really elevating the game through post
launch season so you mentioned that pve
is coming in 2023. now can you tell us
how the development is going and why the
team is committed to bringing these type
of experiences into overwatch we're all
so invested in the world of overwatch
and and the heroes that live in it and
through the years we've developed
cinematics animated shorts and graphic
novels for our players who just want to
get deeper into the lore
with pve we have an opportunity to go a
step further to go deeper into diverse
storytelling in ways that we really just
haven't been able to before
so we are planning to expand the
overwatch universe through these seasons
that we just described and we will start
delivering this pve gameplay in 2023 pve
will be delivered through the live
service and that means we'll be able to
deliver and tell more overwatch stories
and create more opportunities to
experience our heroes here's a sneak
peek at what we're working on
the team's goal for pve and overwatch 2
is to basically move the overall story
of overwatch 4. we've told a lot of
short stories along the way there are a
lot of 2b continues it's time for us to
answer those questions
close off some of those stories ask new
questions so the new game will
definitely move the overall canon of the
lore of overwatch ford get those doors
open for the pvp live service for
certain seasons you're also going to get
some pve maps you'll be fighting null
sector and at least some of the maps
they've come back and they're mad so
it's overwatch's job to take them out
there's going to be content for you to
immerse yourself in and continue to play
over and over again a lot of the older
guys from the original overwatch team
they're coming back but they need help
with some of the younger generation like
brigitta and lucio so
we're going to tell the story of how
overwatch basically gets back together
another thing we want to do with the
story is to showcase more of where the
characters are from for example torbjorn
is from gothenburg players will get a
chance to see what torbjorn's factory
looks like you can play pve with your
friends and immerse yourself in the
world and stay inside of it a little bit
longer
wow this is incredible it's so great to
get that first sneak peek so thank you
so much for sharing that before i let
you run off is there anything you would
like to say to the community watching
yeah we are
so excited for today and we're so
excited for you all to be able to see
everything that we want to show you and
we really cannot wait for
october 4th when we're all playing this
game together neither can i now we'll
also take a deeper look at a brand new
hero that's right jungkook queen who
will be playable for the first time
during the beta later this month already
now before we do that though we thought
we'd take a look at jungle queen's
origin story to get to know the next
great overwatch character a little
better paul aaron we appreciate you
spending some time with us today best of
luck to you and of course your entire
team as you gear up for that launch
let's take a look
[Music]
this is
[Music]
she went
[Music]
well i know sacrifice and i know play
omnics newton's raiders many iceland
junk hurt down there's more to make and
when i'm done none of this will remain
there will be a reckoning
[Applause]
wow just wow what an unbelievable new
hero and we will dive deeper into jungle
queen but first i wanted to introduce
art director dion rogers and a few new
faces to the show we have narrative
designer miranda moyer and cinematic
director ben dye thank you guys so much
for joining welcome yeah thank you for
having us
i'm really excited to share this it
takes an army to create a game
i mean the effort is clearly paying off
that short was just so much fun to watch
now it's been such an exciting week for
everyone watching but i'm sure for you
three as well uh players have learned
that the next beta is coming on june
28th can you tell me a little bit more
about what we can expect to see in this
beta the biggest thing is open the
console players this time we're gonna
add a new map rio
junker queen will be playable finally so
this should be pretty fun i mean i
personally can't wait to get my hands on
jungle queen and you're representing her
right there with the cool shirt as well
what a great segue so let's talk more
about the newest overwatch hero i think
it's super exciting i know everybody has
been really anticipating this character
for a long time she's been super
prominent in our lore ever since the
junkertown map came out and i think
people have really been looking forward
to finally getting to experience
everything that she has to offer what
makes jungkook queen so unique and why
do you think the oh players will love
her
so junker queen is interesting usually
when we start a character we do a bunch
of drawings and and we have a little
story but she was kind of born out of
the junkertown map we started to create
this map that was associated with
roadhog and junkrat this narrative
started to appear where they've been
kicked out of the city and so we're like
who kicked them out and we're like well
maybe there's some sort of leader so we
had the kind of junkertown decree that
you can see in the level
and then over time it kind of developed
that it was a queen during the short
we're actually developing her
personality she's full of attitude you
know that's what we love about her is
she she's really really strong so she's
very recognizable and obviously the lore
behind her um is very interesting so
some of that potentially can bounce off
what the the game design will be it's
great to hear that it's just such a
collaboration with the overwatch team
yeah this this is the fun part about
working together uh the overwatch
universe it's filled with memorable
heroes and as you say yourself ben it
does take a village of dedicated
developers to really bring each one of
those to life but in a meaningful way so
let's take a deeper look at the making
of jungle queen
when we started on chucker queen first
we have to decide what kind of role
she's going to take so
she's a tank she's a really aggressive
tank you know we didn't want her to be
kind of a reinhardt style stay back and
guard her team she's got this very
ferocious nature and we wanted for that
to be represented in her game play as
well personally what i'm most excited
about junker queen is just her big axe
you know just to be able to swing that
thing around is awesome it's always
great to have some sort of anchor point
to make sure we really incorporate this
axe into her abilities
her secondary we call jagged blade if
you do your quick melee attack she will
kind of swing with the blade instead of
a normal punch it does a little bit of
extra damage and creates a wound on the
enemy so she can throw the blade as her
secondary fire and it's really a great
sort of skill shot to be able to land on
an enemy especially like a moving enemy
if you can land it and after you throw
it she'll recall it and it the force of
recalling it
if it's stuck into somebody will let you
pull them forward so she can actually
kind of pull people to herself if you
can manage to stick that blade into
somebody for trekker queen's ultimate we
have an ability called rampage she
creates this kind of whirlwind of
magnetized metal including her weapons
and it rolls around her and then she
dashes forward and you try to go through
as many enemies as possible and tag them
all up that also wounds everybody which
is really important because it's very
easy to hit with this large effect so it
heals you for a lot but also it creates
a debuff on the enemies that reduces the
healing that they receive to zero
our sound designer has done an
incredible job with her she's full of
snarky fun to the way she plays so all
throughout her kit there's little guitar
sounds actually hidden so if you listen
to her axe she pulls it out and there's
a big screech on the guitar strings and
she pulls it forward we have a wonderful
actor named leah who we found after a
huge global search trying to find the
right voice for her here i am it's
really amazing when the right actor
matches the character and the
personality you feel the sort of magic
that comes out of it i think players are
gonna love her she's scary she's awesome
she's a departure from any other hero
that we have here you know this is just
a straightforward badass character she's
just been so much fun to work on and i'm
just so glad to get her in people's
hands by me
the queen of junkertown has arrived so
how does the jungle queen fit into the
overall world of overwatch i think
junker queen's pretty interesting
because there have been previous rulers
of junkertown uh junker queen was not
always the queen and the old rulers of
junkertown have always been kind of
content to just you know lord over the
city but junk queen she has very big
acts and big ideas to go along with it
what did you aim to achieve when
developing jungle queen we want to tell
deeper stories for our heroes have
heroes that are connected to the world
of the game big thing for overwatch 2 is
to move the lore of overwatch along so
these type of heroes help that what are
her abilities and how do those abilities
actually make her successful in the role
she's in what's pretty awesome about
this hero she was developed when 5v5
from the start she was never a part of
the 6v6 world of overwatch knowing she's
the only tank on the team
what abilities that will help bolster
the team
she has this commanding shout it boosts
the speed and armor of the heroes around
her so
especially you need to push through a
choke she does the shout all the players
hear it they move forward she has a
bunch of weapons you know she i think
she named one of her weapons right yeah
her knife that she throws and pulls back
is named gracie
a lot of her abilities kind of drain on
the heroes and gives her health back her
ultimate basically it shoots you forward
and you do this whirlwind with her ex
that it does a bit like a big auntie
nade on everybody around you she's very
aggressive and then people are gonna
have a ton of fun playing it are there
any particular maps uh you feel that
jungle queen plays really well on
getting close is where she's pretty
dangerous so maps that have a
nice flank routes allow her to get in
closer to the enemy and then start to do
her what she does best is reckoning
so another big piece of news over the
weekend that got the overwatch community
just
uh with excitement uh was of course the
tease of your new cinematic trailer the
wastelander uh which we're going to
premiere here in just a few moments but
before we do uh ben can you tell us a
little bit more about it i remember in
the in the very beginning of our story
room jam sections there's talk about
what type of story you want to tell
right should we include junk rash we
include rojo but ultimately i think we
wanted to center
our focus on exactly on our main
character it's a character reveal it's
potentially a sort of a revenge origin
story you know actually give a little
bit more lore into junkertown how she
become the queen how was that society
being
governed you know prior to to she become
the queen well you and the team you guys
pour so much love and time into these
cinematics and introduce heroes and it
really shines through i want to thank
all three of you for taking the time to
sit down with me today and sharing all
of this amazing information
i know the fans at home are on the edges
of their seats so am i waiting to see it
so let's take a look at the world
premiere of the och 2's new cinematic
the wastelander featuring the latest
hero jungle queen
take them out with the rest of the
garbage
let the wasteland deal with them
[Music]
what's happening
what
i'm not allowed to have a bad dream
[Music] [Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
no wastelander
has ever made it to the reckoning before
[Applause]
but here i am
[Applause]
a free-for-all with zero rules
and the survivor
gets the throne
not until
today
[Music]
[Applause]
did you really think this would be a
fair fight
you don't survive the reckoning
unless the winner
grabs your mercy
that's why i've got to win this
all right
let's get this started
huh
[Music]
scavengers like you ain't so bad
[Music]
you know how to
[Music]
come on big boy
did i marry what are you smiling about
if you're smart enough to run the
tinkles
not you'd be any better
at least i won't shoot my friends in the
back
[Music]
[Music]
because we're stronger
[Music]
[Applause]
not in this arena
[Music]
[Music]
this meathead has a bigger magnet
[Music]
that could have gone better
[Music]
oh
you idiot i'll kill you for that
no
not today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mercy
i'll give you
the same mercy you showed my family 13
years ago
get out of my city
[Applause]
but now they're probably wondering what
sort of changes i'll make around here
well buckler
they're about to find out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well that about wraps things up for
today here at blizzard i want to thank
each and every one of you for tuning in
and make sure to follow play overwatch
on social for all the latest news and
announcements about overwatch 2. i can't
wait to see you all in game